[Music]
well the new administration's decision
to stop border wall construction
has forced crews to put down tools this
kills me and walk away in the middle of
work by the way
this is a wall we already paid for a
decision that one arizona sheriff says
left behind
a roadway for smugglers sheriff mark
daniels is in charge of
cochise county which covers 83 miles of
the u.s mexican border
he joins us now sheriff we paid for the
wall to be built
along with the technology and along with
the roads now we're paying to move the
walls store the wall or destroy the wall
and guess what the illegals according to
what you're telling us
are actually using it to get into the
country in what way
well good morning brian it's it's a
product product of politics within
policing
and i've always said that that has no
business in our business in the business
of policing and what we do on this
border
in our communities they when president
biden
rescinded the emergency order on the
southwest border it stopped resources
and stopped construction on our border
as a result of that one area where the
fence is not complete we get five or six
groups a day coming across there
uh it's opened up the border it opened
up the mess
okay to come in this country this
administration
owns this decision and what it's doing
is it's forcing us back to 2019 where we
had the largest
what i call crime scene in the country
to include the largest
humanitarian situation going on
so what we're seeing is is stills that
you guys sent us
how did you get these pictures what
should everyone at home know about these
pictures
these pictures come off our we have our
own camera system that works collected
with
the cbp these pictures i'm showing you
came off our camera system
where you see the smuggling coming
through our deserts it's wide open right
now
it's wide open and with the uh chaos
going on the border
based on these administrative decisions
and and it just
we saw this in 2019 brian where 141
countries breached our southwest border
in the first nine months
over a thousand gang members 822
assaults on agents
800 and 271
deaths on our border this is a crime
scene and this is what we just
put together we had it we had it under
control this was frustrating
and now it's going back to 2019. it's
frustrating
i mean i don't want to get you into
politics but we just fired 15 000 people
working in a pipeline that had zero
impact on the environment
and then he went over to the border
which was working and blew it up on pure
political purposes and made your life
miserable
and made our country put our country in
greater danger keep in mind some of
these numbers and these numbers don't
lie
uh border encounters in the fiscal year
2021 71 thousand
nine twenty two in october seventy two
thousand ninety one in november
seventy three thousand in december
seventy eight thousand in january
that's almost three hundred thousand now
look in 2014 vice president joe biden
uh said when there were 68 000 border
crossing unaccompanied miners crossing
they said it was a crisis he called it a
tragedy that was 188 per day
today we're projected to have 117 000
this year
what's he going to call it then what
changed
well politics changed uh politics
changed ideologies changed
uh it's it's hypocritical to be honest
with you brian
what we've seen in the past and where
we're at today is very hypocritical
by this administration it goes against
the grain of the cdc
i would love to hear dr faushi who
nobody is talking about what's going on
the southwest border when it comes to
the health pandemic in this country
they are not testing them they're being
released without being tested
into communities and then you look at
the public safety aspect of this
uh it's upsetting it's almost like we're
not part of this country which is very
upsetting yeah it's what's in the best
interests of the country
when's the last time one said to ask you
if you were a democrat or republican
it's nothing to do with it it is just
one's right and one's wrong
and you say this remain new mexico
policy which has now been blown up
you say the the new proposal by the
mexican leader could bring
600 to 800 000 mexican and central
american uh illegal immigrants a year
coming here yes it they give you an
example brian
of just our camera system which is up to
a thousand
cameras we deployed 700 at a time
we a year ago today we were running just
in our camera system 300 to 400
a month in august when the politics
kicked up we jumped up to 1200 a month
in december was over 2500 uh
entries to illegal injuries let me say
to include over 500 pounds of illicit
drugs
i just got the charts there today it's
skyrocketing back to numbers we saw in
2019
the reason we have mpp and these other
programs president trump put in place
was because the 2019 caravan and surges
it worked
it's not working now yep
uh sheriff i feel bad for how your
life's changed because of pure politics
uh sheriff mark daniels please if the
biden people show up tell them the truth
that you just told our audience sheriff
thanks so much
thank you